in einer zeit in der in afghanistan die
frauen für ihre rechte kämpfen müssen
angst haben vor den taliban angst vor
einer kompletten verschleierung haben da
muss ich sagen da ist es mir
sprichwörtlich schleierhaft wie eine kim
kardashian mit über 250 millionen
follower weil der met gala in new york
komplett verschleiert von kopf bis fuß
in schwarz gestern zu sehen sein konnte
ich muss sagen dass es für mich ein
politisches statement und die taliban
können das ganz klar als propaganda
nutzen ich muss eigentlich einfach nur
fassungslos als ich die bilder gesehen
habe ja
ich hab's ja auch gesehen und die
tatsache dass sie aber wert darauf
gelegt hat dass zu dieser meldung noch
dazu gesagt hat dass sie vorher vier
stunden geschminkt wurde und in diesem
outfit wo wir nichts gesehen hat das
macht das ganze ja zu einer affen nummer
zuerst gesehen hat wirklich gedacht wow
das ist quasi eine kunstinstallation
also es ist das gegenteil damit gemeint
ist ist ein mahnmal so als ich dann so
langsam begriffen habe dass der krebs
der darsteller offenbar nicht so
ausreicht um so zu denken sondern dass
das 1 1 gemeint ist da muss ich auch
sagen fehlt mir jegliches verständnis
wenngleich ich die show an sich ziemlich
um busted fand also ich finde auch
dieses thema ist ja wieder so dass ich
sage die taliban werden ja in allem
hofiert und das sollten wir ja gerade
jetzt nicht machen ich sage es mal
entweder verehren wir die taliban dann
passt das alles zusammen oder wir sagen
das was die machen ist falsch dann
müssen wir das auch demonstrieren also
in dieser sendung haben sie schon zwei
punkte gemacht die talsperren wenn also
deshalb müssen wir sagen wir müssen doch
nicht denen jetzt alles nachmachen
sondern wir müssen zeigen dass wir sagen
das ist nicht richtig was sie machen und
müssen praktisch dann nicht die schulen
trennen und müssen nicht auch die
kleidung entsprechen nach machen denn
dann fühlen die sich ja hofiert und
sagen was wir machen ist richtig und das
ist fatal also ich glaube ich glaube
darin liegt der entscheidende gedanke
wenn man dieses publikum hat wie die
kardashian
über 280 millionen verloren instagram
wenn man alle scheinwerfer auf sich
zieht und wenn man sich in der
westlichen welt sozusagen die taschen
vollmacht und die freiheiten genießen
dann muss man seine eigene bühne nutzen
um das gegen symbol zu schicken also
vielleicht eine mode inszenierung die
super sexy ist die sexieste mode
inszenierung aller zeiten die fast an
nacktheit heranreicht die sozusagen mit
allen tabus spielt um und das muss man
in die welt der taliban schicken als
quasi ja wo aber auch die vig die
schlichten follower begreift ja denn
wenn es denn eine ein stummer protest
ein schrei des protest gewesen sein
sollte als dass man es sich im
nachhinein darstellt dann begreifen es
die die es begreifen sollten ja nicht
ein wir müssen unsere bühne nutzen sie
ist gekommen wir steuern auf eine
fußball weltmeisterschaft in katar zu da
ist es genau das gleiche eine weltbühne
die von einem system benutzt werden soll
um werbung für dieses system zu machen
und mein plädoyer wäre er lasst uns
diese bühne denen entreißen und das ist
auch so wenn ich mir vorstelle des
fast dass man mit unserem blick schon
sagt und baut es geht aber jetzt weit
dann wäre es genau richtig gewesen um
das signal in die leben der anderen zu
senden und zu sagen dafür kämpfen wir
auch dass das bei uns geht und das ist
erlaubt oder dass wir wollen dass sogar
das ist ein zeichen der meinungsäußerung
der persönlichen freiheit und unsere
unseres gesellschaftlichen begriff ist
des zusammenlebens das war jetzt
vielleicht eher
kontraproduktiv zumal die anderen das
natürlich für ihre werbe schoss
verwenden könnte definitiv dass das das
halt wirklich das problem die taliban
können ja wirklich jetzt zu den jungen
frauen sagen
wir haben jetzt mehr kaschieren auf
unserer seite das ist ja super skurril
also für mich ganz einfach nur an
dummheit mag sein dass es bei der met
gala so ist dass man die outfits
monatelang vorbereiten muss aber eine
kim kardashian die muss nur einmal so
machen und da hat die das nächste auto
auf der stange was perfektes jahr und
unglaublich ist das ist alles ganz
einfach mehr oder weniger schon lange
vorbereitet ist dann muss man natürlich
das momentum nutzen und sie zieht sich
daraus im laufe der zeit ja sie reist
serie vielleicht ist gewarnt runter und
setzt damit ein denkmal die gesamte
westliche welt und an dann werden
stattdessen zieht sie es so nicht aus
sondern durch und das
wurde ja noch diskutiert ob sie es
überhaupt selber war also ob sie
überhaupt darunter gestellt hatte habe
ich gedacht jetzt wird er noch toller
seinen universitäten in kabul waren ja
auch verschleierte frauen die dann reden
gehalten haben wie großartig das ist
doch alles ist er im und am ende war
dann aber die fragen haben sich darunter
vielleicht auch männern und steckt das
heißt wenn sie es jetzt nicht mal selbst
war hat sie eigentlich dass die taliban
propaganda in kabul und afghanistan nach
gemacht hatten universitäten und ich
finde es furchtbar ich finde kim
kardashian hat damit ein zeichen gesetzt
dass es doch tolles verschleiert zu
werden eine frau und das ist es
definitiv nicht also ich verstehe
natürlich eins nicht ich sag mal das war
schon immer so wenn ich an etwas kritik
üben dann kann ich das nicht noch
verherrlichen in dem ich selber vor
mache und das ist ja fatal ich sag mal
was ich kritisiere kann ich selbst nicht
nachmachen das muss ich es gegenteil vor
machen und nicht das was ich kritisiert
habe mache ich morgen nach dann ist das
ja eine verherrlichung dieser geschichte
und dafür stehe ich schon die logik
nicht
[Musik]